Speaker 1: David. I'm starting to see
headlines that Joe Biden's approval rating
is collapsing. Is this true? So first, let's
answer the question about the approval rating.
Then let's talk about what's actually going on.
If you look at 538, Joe Biden's approval has only
dropped like within the margin of error. When
I looked most recently, Joe Biden's approval on
an average of approval ratings went from fifty
three to fifty one point five. That's a really,
really small change to say. It's statistically
significant yet. But let's imagine that it's
true that Joe Biden's approval is declining a
little bit. I think there's a couple of things
to think about. First of all, it might be more
important to look at disapproval than approval
on disapproval. Joe Biden's disapproval has gone
up from an average of 36 to an average of 43.
My guess is that that's right wingers who have
shifted from having no real opinion to saying
they don't like what Joe Biden is doing, probably
in part because of the propaganda, particularly
around vaccines and covid and masks that has been
spreading among right wing media circles. But I
think in this case, it's a little more important
to zoom out. It's very common that a normal
president, not Trump, a normal president, comes in
with a relatively high or higher approval rating.
And then over time, their approval begins to
erode and their disapproval starts to go up.
Why is this a lot of this approval disapproval
stuff is based on has the president done anything
that you don't like? And even if you've
liked a bunch of stuff Joe Biden has done,
there will be some people where in February
Biden does something they don't like.
They now disapprove and they're not going back.
And then in March, Joe Biden does something
different that another little cohort doesn't like
and now they disapprove and they never go back. So
the erosion of approval throughout a presidency
is relatively common with Donald Trump.
He actually left office with the lowest
approval of his presidency. I think it was
twenty nine percent, according to I think it
was Gallup. So that's relatively atypical.
Also atypical would be like for. George W. Bush
after 9/11 had like 80 something percent approval,
that was a unique sort of circumstance that that
explain that. So it's not particularly concerning.
I think that there's a there is this gets me
back to Biden needs a major accomplishment this
calendar year. Another major accomplishment. The
vaccine rollout has been huge. Now, the problem is
too many people don't want the vaccine getting
covid stimulus done within a couple of months.
That was huge. We're now in the second part of the
year. We're in the third quarter. We're going to
be in the fourth quarter before you know it.
Biden has to get something else done. If it's
the infrastructure deal that could be useful,
that could actually lead to a couple of points
of approval increasing. But I think that this is
all pointing to a very interesting 20, 22 cycle
also in in support of Democrats in 2022. It's also
really important that Joe Biden get something else
done and then we'll see what happens as far as
the approval rating is concerned. But so far,
everything is pretty typical, slight erosion of
approval. But it's time for Joe to get something
else done. We've got a great bonus show for
you today. Don't miss it. Sign up at Join
Pakman Dotcom. We'll have Ferren cousins for a
few days and also Jesse Dolma for a few days,
replacing me on upcoming shows. I will then be
back. It's going to be incredible. Please be
nice to them guys. Please be nice to them.
Unidentified: I would appreciate that.